so australia is running an experiment on
what happens when you don't have the
equivalent of the communications decency
act section 230 on the books in
australia it appears that the high court
has determined that media companies are
liable for the content that any other
user posts to their website or facebook
page and this is something that a lot of
people think should be adopted in the
united states because they feel that
tech companies have too much power and
they're silencing voices though to date
they've been hamstrung by section 230
and the first amendment to the us
constitution now i'm not an australian
lawyer take this with a grain of salt
i'm doing my best to parse what i can
see coming out of the australian courts
but at first blush this decision seems
to be the opposite of section 230 and
that media companies might be liable for
these comments so they will be running a
natural experiment as to what actually
happens when the internet doesn't have
the equivalent of the first amendment or
section 230 and i'm as interested as you
are in finding out what kind of
unintended consequences if any come as a
result of this finding